In my career, what I've always tried my best to do,...
...whether on television or through film,...
...is to say something about how men and women really behave;...
...to say how we experience shame, how we love and how we rage,...
...how we fail, how we retreat, persevere and how we overcome.
I've interviewed and portrayed people...
...who've withstood some of the ugliest things life can throw at you,...
...but the one quality all of them seem to share...
...is an ability to maintain hope for a brighter morning, even during our darkest nights.
So I want all the girls watching here and now to know that a new day is on the horizon.
And when that new day finally dawns,...
...it will be because of a lot of magnificent women,...
...many of whom are right here in this room tonight,...
...and some pretty phenomenal men fighting hard to make sure...
...that they become the leaders who take us to the time...
...when nobody ever has to say "Me too" again.
Thank you.